coal mining and Germany Social Democrats
have ruled the town of bad comment for
decades mining operations may have long
since ground to a halt but traditions
die hard almost everyone here is a
former miner and most have always voted
for the SPD it's the classic Workers
Party for us there have always been lots
of miners at times 600,000 of us yes we
miners made North rhine-westphalia great
and the Social Democratic Party has
always stood by us especially during
labor disputes all that's history now
and has been consigned to the local
museum the last mine in Germany's hula
region will shut down next year the trio
of coal labor unions and the SPD still
make their mark on Bank common the small
town at the edge of the war region is an
SPD stronghold the party won more than
50 percent here in recent state
elections the Social Democrats also call
the shots in the City Council with mayor
Holland Shifa who was recently
re-elected with nearly 70 percent of the
vote went to some opponents say you can
paint a broom handle red here and put it
forward it will still get elected
well the SPD hasn't put forward a broom
handle but instead active women and men
who make an effort and that's ultimately
rewarded other parties have always had a
tough time and back common and complain
of the SPD's dominance oh yeah oh yes
party of the majority in principle they
can do what they want so we're always
out voted
I think this excessive power is not good
for democracy for the Democrat II and
the SPD's hold has been slipping almost
everyone with a plot at these allotment
gardens used to vote for the party but
that's no longer the case this is
somehow the trust is gone and that's
really hard I'm still in the party and I
still vote for them but I know many
people who've turned away because the
party no longer makes policies for the
little guy
money my vid and that's also difficult
in a city that had to cope with a
radical structural change in recent
decades by moving away from coal while
the chemicals industry remains new
projects have emerged such as the hunter
marina which has provided jumps and
money at first mayor Schafer had to win
his comrades over to the idea of the
project now he has plans for a
waterfront luxury residential complex
that's mine that's what the SPD comrades
are doing here they have the majority
and the SPD has not only modernized
itself it's also promoted as structural
change modernization in the city and in
the economy and in the population and
local politician Hollen Shifa has a tip
for the SPD struggling lead candidate
Martin Schultz as well as for his own
party in general perhaps you can learn
something from Becca without sounding
boastful making sure to address on the
one hand social classes that aren't
traditionally SPD voters here we've
succeeded in the SPD stronghold of Bank
common tradition and progress still go
together in one People's Party